hi there steve kaufman and it's day one
of the 90 day challenge which in my case
is a challenge to
improve as much as possible in polish
a quick comment here
the whole idea of the 90-day challenge
is that we push each other that we help
each other encourage each other
ask questions of each other and so forth
if you have questions you can put them
here
below the video
you can put them at my blog and there'll
be a link below in the description
uh
you can ask them on the forum at link
ask me questions and once a week at the
end of the week i will make a video in
which i will try to answer the questions
that i get now starting in the polish
let me be quite up front here i have
on link i have over 6 000
words that theoretically i know in
polish most of that has been
i have been gone through who is she
kimona yest
uh in polish which is the 26
lesson
silly little story that we have in every
language that links i've done that
and there are a lot of very good
beginner material that um
have been created for linked by some of
our members
excellent quality so i've gone through a
lot of the beginner material
i have
attempted an audio book with a short
audiobook called
mendel gudansky
very difficult for me very nice narrator
nice voice i can kind of listen along
and read but i don't really understand
it there's far too many words that i
don't know i have a much easier time
reading
newspaper articles that i import into
link and then create links and and learn
that way so my strategy is first week
i'm going to really go after who is she
simple content really sort of relearn
the stuff that i kind of have learned
before and i know that relearning things
that we have forgotten in fact
give us a better grasp of those things
so i'm going to focus largely on that
and hope to move into more demanding
material as soon as i've kind of
feel comfortable enough to do so if
anyone knows of audio like podcasts on
current events which also have
transcripts that would be wonderful as
it is right now i can access podcasts
without transcripts in polish i can also
find obviously newspaper articles which
have no audio if i could find a
combination in his on subjects like
history or or current events where i'm
familiar with the background and if i
could then listen and read that kind of
material it would help me but in the
meantime i'm starting with
the material that i've already covered
before which is largely who is she and i
look forward to your questions and i
want to hear how you guys are all making
out thanks for listening talk to you
soon bye for now